so this is a new revelation that I've
come across this year as well is we know
women like successful Men We Know
successful men have options successful
men will exercise those options and
often they're dealing with multiple
women on a simultaneous basis right
they're dealing with they're they're
dating multiple women on a non
monogamous Fashion on a simultaneous
basis or spinning plates and the best
ones will always rise to the top and
I've lost count of this is again another
Trend that I've noticed in this past
year where women in the past would do
things to Captivate a
man um they will ask leading questions
like hey where do we stand or where is
this going um I really dig your Vibe you
know are you seeing anybody else I'm not
seeing anybody else sort of thing like
women in the past have done that very
naturally and I think is a function
again again one of the things I've
noticed this past year is that we're
seeing
women somewhere or or some collective of
you know whatever you want to call it
the Matrix if you want where they're
being told not to chase successful men
make an effort is what they say dress up
take a shower put on your makeup do your
hair smell nice they'll throw themselves
at these guys but the moment that they
expect him to cow out to to them and I
think this is because they're so used to
sing right like sing is a pandemic this
is something that I'm not even going to
dive down a rabbit hole on CU I think
it's obvious to most people that watch
and are familiar with my content the
notion that that sing is new is totally
it's been around for a while
but I think that a lot of it
is clouding women's judgment and their
ability to look at themselves in a
mirror and assess them correctly assess
themselves correctly
attention does not equate value to women
but what they're doing is they taking
all the free attention the likes the
comments the DMS everything they get
from the Sim like I'm not even talking
about only fans models only fans models
are on another level okay I'm talking
about the average girl out there with a
job gets up in the morning makes her
breakfast you know Becky puts on her
clothes looks at her furniture before
she leaves admires her place and her
diploma goes to work we're talking about
Becky here right the average goal has
been told not to chase successful men
and a lot of these
women straight up are are screwing up
big time because a lot of these guys
would give them what they're looking for
if they made themselves these guys best
option I'll talk about that probably
more on a uh ladies night podcast but
just one of the notes that I've uh made
here is that women have been told to
definitely not Chase successful men it's
becoming more and more common um I'm
also seeing it when I get the successful
guys calling on my shows who are
interested in women and they're finding
you know these
gals delusions to be out there
uncompromising and in some degree
unacceptable marriage is still dumb uh
you know that's that's not going to
change I don't see laws or legislation
or anything improving in a positive
direction I think that if you're
contemplating getting marriage es in a
country like Canada or any of the states
in the US that are hostile towards
fathers um you're marching into look man
there's a chapter in my book on why
smart men don't marry there's a lot of
information out there in my podcast I
even did a podcast in the past year on
why I wouldn't get married again it's
just dumb don't do it get your head
around it properly I'm not saying don't
have children I'm not saying don't pass
on your seed I'm saying don't do
anything in such a way that the state is
is in in a position to decide what
happens to your wealth and access to
your kids
okay um women still want it all what can
I say they all want it
all but
again they want it all from guys that
they already like that they're unwilling
to make an effort or to chase because
they've been told that they're beautiful
that they're the best that there is even
even
like we're seeing uh what do they call
them fat fluenc or you know these obese
influencers that have like fat
acceptance is killing people right we've
seen in the last few months a lot of
headlines in the media where you know 30
late 30s early 40s um influencers on Tik
Tok influencers whatever you want to
call them have been dying off because of
their obesity is killing them um
women want it all without any sort of
concession um there's
a there's a lot of good women out there
but there's a lot
more not really good women out there
there's deluded women out there that
have been told a whole bunch of
comforting lies that do not serve them
that areen going to get them nowhere
close to what they want they'll they'll
you know they'll say I just want an
awesome guy I just want to marry an
awesome guy and then everything that
precedes that is complicate life justify
why everything it's not just guys that
do it women do it too like I said women
still want it all but there's a total
disconnect between what all is and well
sorry there's a there's a total
disconnect between what the all they
think that they are entitled to and what
they can actually
get so we're going to continue to see
problems out there um there's going to
be a big disconnect between men and I
mean I'm trying to bridge the Gap with
the ladies night show with moff is what
I'm trying to do like we're trying to
have some legit productive conversations
but it's like pulling teeth from these
chicks sometimes right you ask them a
straightforward question and they and
they dance around the subject because
they want to manage their reputation
they don't want to come off as
judgmental or I'm not interested in that
kind of guy because of this reason it's
like just let like women want honesty
from men but they're unwilling to
provide it and you know a setting when
we get into these discussions and rabbit
holes it's it it's just
so men are a lot easier to deal with
like I'll be completely honest with you
men are a lot easier to communicate with
and deal with and fix their problems um
because women they have a totally
different set of issues similar but
totally different
set another point I got here is men
still want obscene shortcuts they still
want to get out of jail for free they
still want to do as little as possible
like is a bar really that low for me
this is this is a consistent theme that
guys think about right this is the
shortcut life that they want to
subscribe to I keep seeing women on
Twitter and Reddit saying that all men
have to do to find a girlfriend is just
be genuinely nice have proper grooming
proper hygiene some interest and also
have any kind of job even if it's low
paying so by that definition of what
women are holding out to men these guys
who want shortcuts are okay with going
to work at the Walmart job making
whatever it is that they get paid having
some interest in I don't know fortnite
or whatever GTA 5 67 whatever happens to
be trending right now you know they take
a shower and brush their hair and their
teeth probably um is this all it takes
to get a girlfriend or is this just
something people just say so they can
get internet points this is the whole
thing with dudes man they listen to to
these chicks all the freaking time and
even the ones that are better even like
the red pilled girls or like the manow
swamp girls that are doing podcast
circuits or they run shows and they you
know they say all these things that seem
interesting to these guys they're not
they're not delivering the full picture
most women don't deliver anything close
to the full picture even the ones that
some of you guys which I'm going to tell
you right now you're dorks if you if you
pay attention to these stupid
conversations that these gals are are
having are totally missing the point
they're they're they're completely
missed and it's why we have so many guys
today that start with this mindset with
this thinking process of just being and
doing the bare minimum what is what is
the closest what is the easiest way to
get from point A to
intimacy or whatever it is they're
looking for point a to a date you know
whatever point a to a A
Kiss what is the shortest path between
here and here and
what's in the path between here and what
you want is dressed in overalls and
looks like work and requires you to fix
a lot of about yourself you're
probably too poor you're probably too
fat you're probably too boring you're
probably too insignificant you probably
don't have very many captivating
interest sort of things and when you
solve a lot of these problems for you
again I want to make this clear it's not
to get the girls or for girls women just
happen to be a byproduct of living a
better life for yourself again guys you
shouldn't be watching these podcasts if
you're not willing to do the work if all
you want is shortcuts or a flip to
switch there's ads somewhere that are
that are going to sell you some pop a
pill and you'll lose 20 pounds in a
couple week that's it's it's literally
true they they've they've actually
advertised what's it called OIC or
something like that semag glutin I can't
remember what it's called but these
pharmaceutical companies which I'm
making a fortune in right now because of
the Investments that I put in their
stocks because I knew people were going
to buy this people guys are
going out buying some EpiPen thing
sticking it in their fat belly and
they're and they're losing weight
they're not losing fat they're actually
becoming fatter because they lose bone
density and muscle more than they lose
fat but they're losing weight and they
think that this shortcut will get them
you know this this is one of the
critical problems with Society the
ultimate problem with Society is people
want shortcuts not just guys scals too
but guys for the most part when it comes
to solving problems in their life
you know telling them to get a gym
membership and eating better and moving
more and picking up heavy and
putting it down and going to dojo and
getting punched in the face and really
being humbled that's too much work
that's they'll they'll sit there and
they'll play video games for
hours oh look I levered up my character
to a level 72 warrior with Ironclad gold
diamond black and purple you know like
they'll like they'll level up a
character in a video game but do nothing
to level up themselves in real life
it's a real problem and honestly guys
like if that's your solution to
everything it's never going to work for
you man
never another note I made here I'll get
to call and Q&A stuff in a second um
give me a few more minutes to sort of
rip through this
but there is a
fantastic fan freaking tastic
access now to data on the
internet the amount of women that will
tell on
themselves don't listen to what women
say watch what women are doing and the
amount of women using social media
doesn't matter if it's Tik Tok X Twitter
Facebook
Reddit YouTube whatever it had Instagram
whatever it happens to be the amount of
women that tell on themselves that will
reveal the kind of character that they
have is so easy today like in never in
any other time in history has it been
this easy to find out what a chick's
made of you don't have to date her for
six months to even see what she's all
about you can literally just do a quick
search on her social media the way that
she holds herself out to and again I see
this on on the ladies night show women
will come on I'm a very conservative
God-fearing Christian and I'm looking
for a very conservative God-fearing
Christian man I want to have a family
and you go and look at their social
media and it's skin everywhere tits an
ass right
um nothing about Biblical verses nothing
about the religious convictions you know
you ask them well if you're so strongly
you know convicted about you know
religion and God and the woman of God
and all this sort of stuff and you want
to get married and you want to have a
family then you must be a virgin right
well no I'm not a vir yeah I can see on
your social media all the partying and
the Vegas and and the Cancun and the
abas and the travel and the the box of
dicks that you have everywhere it's just
it like today at no other time in
history has been easier to see what a
chick's made of than it is just to look
them up on social
media women aren't covering their
footsteps bizarre to me you you know
you'd think with the reputation
management that they use when it comes
to the ladies night you know
conversation you ask them a
straightforward question how much money
does a guy need to make to be with you
Becky you make $96,000 a year as a nurse
let's say how much money does a guy need
to make doesn't really matter as long as
he's a nice guy you know would be
totally fine so a Walmart greeter making
$30,000 a year is fine Becky well you
know I'm sure there's some of these guys
that make a little bit more money and
that would be okay but if he's a nice
guy and he hugs me and he tells him I'm
pretty that would be fun you
can see what women do by watching how
they hold themselves out on social media
it's never been easy easier any other
time in history it's super easy now to
size up
chicks it's actually surprising how few
of them cover up their bad choices
especially when bad choices are being
labeled I mean I label like my ex feed
all the time on Twitter I label bad
choices of men and women all the time
it's very very easy to you know discover
what they are I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clip's from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out